a long search finally comes to an end
in january a sriwajya air jet carrying
62 passengers crashed into the java sea
minutes after takeoff search crews have
since been looking for the cockpit voice
recorder
was the last day of search by the ship
we're praying that hopefully
we could find it and thank god last
night on the last night of the continued
search
we found it divers found the devices
casing and beacon in the early days of
their search
but poor conditions made it difficult to
find the recorder itself
and there was no beacon signal to help
the box was retrieved after mud was
sucked up from the seabed
now investigators can cross check its
findings with that of the other black
box
the flight data recorder the message
from the president is to be as open and
transparent as possible to work out the
reason
so that similar incidents do not occur
in the future
early findings from investigators found
technical problems with the 26 year old
boeing 737-500
the cockpit voice recorder is now safely
in jakarta
and in the hands of indonesia's
transport safety commission
it's up to them to investigate its data
and work out
what went wrong on flight sj-182
according to a preliminary report
problems with the automatic throttle
created an imbalance in the thrust of
the aircraft's engines
the cockpit voice recorder is expected
to have recorded the conversations of
the pilots
that investigators will study they need
to know what the crew was doing what
they were talking and what they were
saying to each other
and from the conversations that can
determine whether they were
encountering problems or they didn't see
what was coming
it will take around a week to analyze
its data and the final report is likely
to take months
it's a process that's not uncommon in
indonesia but has one of the worst
aviation records
in asia jessica washington al jazeera
jakarta